you know it's it's crazy to me the
gillette commercial you saw that you
know toxic masculinity yes
i was talking about how i just want an
ad that tells me what you're selling
and then i was skating outside the other
day and it was like a harry's commercial
and it was like
hi this is harry's we sell razors they
cost two dollars
you can order them online they have
three blades and i'm like that's great
that's all i wanted to know thank you
i'll go buy it well you know the left
has this way
of creating the atmosphere that they say
they're they're afraid of or that
they're they're working against i mean i
actually believe
that they've created a lot of racists
just this year based off of the activity
they've engaged in
but they're also terribly afraid of
going back in time they're afraid of
that for racial minorities they're
afraid of that for women
they're afraid of that for gays they're
for you know us living
in another era and what you just said it
actually
you know we may maybe our culture will
get pushed into this
almost like television commercials from
the 1950s when it really was like that
before
like you know buy buy cigarettes they're
delicious and they
they're good for your health you know i
mean it just tells you what the product
is right
raisin bran it's bran and raisins or
milk on it
for breakfast yeah i mean i love it i
think those are these are very like
male sign trick commercials guys are
just like no bs just tell me what it is
but they've tried to manipulate and
catch people and so
i think ads just used to be they didn't
know how to do it now they've figured
out
you can have like a chinchilla screech
in your face quiznos will sell sub
sandwiches or something
and it worked so you know it's true i
mean people are
sick and tired of watching tv watching
commercials and
having to question their morality and
am i a good person am i a bad person am
i am i supposed to be trans
i you know it's i just want to buy milk
do i have to question my gender like i
just want milk yeah no it's it's coming
to the point where it's
it's religion it's like turning on the
tv and saying like have you confessed
your sins today
right the the toxic masculinity ad it's
the
you know you know a lot of people talk
about you i'm sure you've heard of get
what go broke
yes i think there's a lot of
circumstances where it's actually get
broke
try woke where these companies are
failing because they're obsolete
or because their marketing strategy was
bad and they're like let's try wokeness
yes
a lot of celebrities are doing that
right celebrities on the brink of
irrelevance are now you know out with
the black lives matter science and
taking their selfies taking their
selfies for instagram
at the marches and stuff and it's also
um but there's also kind of like the
sad kind of element of it where you know
i've been talking about this a lot too
a lot of these people when you're
walking down the street you feel like
this black lives matter movement is so
popular and well accepted
a sign here a sign here a sign here but
the sign has really become a virtue
signal i think saying
please don't smash my windows exactly
you know and so i think that there are a
lot less people who support the cause
than we think but they're just afraid of
getting looted that's true i think so
uh have you ever been to the bay area
unfortunately yeah and they
you go you go to berkeley you go to
oakland you see the signs all over the
windows yes
that's horrifying yeah but they probably
believe in it um
you don't think i don't think so no and
berkeley in berkeley there are a lot of
stores that do
but there i i went to a bar and they
told me straight up the
anti-trump poster they had was just so
that no one's smashed their windows
and they did not agree with it wow and
we were having a candid conversation
so i think sure you're in berkeley down
the street you know by the university
you're going to find a bunch of
businesses that do believe it
some of these bookstores are like shut
up anarchists bookstores but there are a
lot of businesses
that you're like it's run by you know
chinese immigrants
that don't engage in american politics
and i'm like i'm not sure
they care all that much they're just
saying leave us alone right you know
yeah i'm not i'm not sure if they care
even if you know like
for for us opposing it either they're
just like whatever who cares but sign up
i i don't know why this popped into my
mind but when i was doing a rally
in uh michigan i think a big group of
black lives matter protesters came and
uh they were about 50 percent white um
which is actually a pretty low ratio
it's usually a lot more than that
um but there was a black well there were
several
black people on in my group and so this
black man went over to one of these
white guys holding his black lives
matter sign and the white guy is
shouting at him
you know because he's got a trump hat on
you know he's got like his maga gear and
the white guy's like what are you doing
bro
what are you doing bruh you know and uh
and finally the white guy says
he's like this is just so classic i wish
i had this on film
in fact i might actually but he's there
with a sign and he goes i'm doing this
for you bro
i'm doing this for you bruh and the
guy's like
you can go home i'm good i'm good i'm
good
yeah make america great again i'm good
these the these activists in my opinion
are white supremacists
yeah they they think that they've
invented everything
i mean we've talked about several times
robin d'angelo from white fragility you
know the author yes
she says she's a racist in the book yeah
why are we taking our cues from these
people
it's yeah the whole i haven't read the
book um but i've read a lot of
we have a mutual friend carlin and she
kind of broke broke the book down
uh in chapters on twitter was posting
them and it's
there's so many anecdotes in that book
where i was kind of shocked
at the things that the woman says and
reveals you know just like
when i walk into a room and i see black
people i become very uncomfortable i
i clutch my purse i want to you know
what i'm like that's not a normal
reaction
that's right why would anyone take
advice from someone who's an avowed
racist
right who would say something like that
it's like dude listen you're the one who
needs
uh talking to not me correct i i look i
i grew up second generation mixed race
friends of all different races
and i didn't experience any of this
until i went to occupy wall street yeah
where they literally segregated
everybody
yeah like this is you know this race
here asians go here the black people go
here the mexicans go there
and i was angry i was like this is this
is the most like disgusting thing i've
ever seen
right i couldn't imagine this happening
in my neighborhood you get beat up if
you tried doing something like that yeah
we're all friends with each other
yeah i you know i'm actually i would say
on the opposite end of the spectrum
i love any opportunity when i'm like the
only white person in the room
especially if i'm giving an address or
something like that's one of my favorite
things in the world when i'm addressing
an audience
and it's a racial minority uh majority
or you know something like that because
for me it's a challenge
that i want to end that night knowing
that i thoroughly went over and charmed
everyone in that room based off of what
i had like there's nothing scary about
it for me i love it
like i love it because i'm like by the
time i'm done i am going to be the most
popular white boy and the whole they are
gonna love me
um so yeah it doesn't even occur to me
to be like oh my god there's black
people in the room i gotta run i gotta
run
but not my thing for her it is for all
these activists i have to wonder
you know are you familiar with reset the
clock the meme
it's about male feminists being rapists
like for some reason
you just said a lot of funny words and
one right right sorry so so so the gag
is kind of like it's like oh we got
another one race at the clock
you know like days since we've had a
male feminist exposed
and what some things somebody wrote this
was really fascinating they said the
reason why feminists
are so you know like you know feminist
is because
the reason why they think all men are
bad is because they're surrounded by
male feminists
they're not hanging out with us right
you know the feminists we hang out with
regular people there's like feminists
are like a fringe
but when you have this very small group
of people that have these extremist
ideologies granted they're gaining a lot
of traction in mainstream stuff
when they're only surrounded by abusive
men
who are pretending to care about their
cause to try and sleep with them
they're gonna say all men are bad
because the only men they can see are
bad
well i think that's a reinforcement but
don't you think
my opinion is that everybody has
problems
we all have struggles but only certain
of us get told that those problems and
struggles are because of the color of
our skin our sexual orientation or our
gender
so we all worry sometimes about how
we're gonna pay our bills or
uh how am i gonna get a job or um
am i am i good looking enough am i
whatever enough i whatever
but if people are telling you well
the reason why you feel like you're not
good looking enough is because you're
black or the reason why you don't have
enough money is because you're black or
the reason why
you're worried about this is because
you're gay it's the same problems that
we all have but people are being told
it's different because of them they
don't want you to solve your problems
well sure they want to be the solution
that's how they control you exactly
yes if you were to tell somebody you are
powerful
no one can hold you back stand defiant
and you can do anything
right then you can't control them
correct they know what what they can do
for me i think it's it's a big
difference between why it's the
democrats and the republicans
republicans personal responsibility
individualism the democrats
collective responsibility you're
responsible for your ancestors if we
don't like you but others aren't
and you know we're going to act for the
collective's best interests don't defy
us
what's your view on privilege uh in in
what capacity
do you think it exists in any forms or
do you think oh yeah of course
right sorry absolutely no i mean what
forms do you think it exists in
and how relevant are the forms so i
think the what the left doesn't
understand is is when you take someone
who's not very smart and i mean this
without not
not to be disrespectful they can't
analyze
root causes they can only see the
surface so they have to wonder why it is
that say
a white person tends to have certain
privileges
and so they say ah it must be because he
looks that way right that's a racist
approach racists can't see past skin
color right but if you actually do a
deep analysis there is
majority privilege humans have a
tendency to feel
safer around people who look similar to
them and i'm not talking about race i'm
talking about literally everything
it's why you'll see a man and a woman
holding hands walking on the street
wearing like very similar clothes and
the same
you know you've seen that before right
yeah they that they did a study and
found that
they showed a bunch of pictures to
people and asked them to rate the most
attractive
and one of them was their own face that
was like
like de-texturized a little bit they
viewed themselves
as more attractive the more familiar it
is to them
and that's just you know i think it was
brett weinstein who talks about this
says
that's why we must strive to make sure
we overcome our inherent biases and
things like this
so i do believe there's privileges but i
believe the better way to put it is
majority privilege
if you were to i've been a bunch of
countries where you would not have
privilege
you would like i mean look go to asia i
tell you i tell you this man
um so i i am uh par korean
and this is this this is one of the
reasons why i absolutely detest the
intersectional left because
it's you know when if you're mixed or if
you're asian you're schrodinger's
or you know people person of color
whatever they don't know how to deal
with you
but south korea korea in general they're
very
racist they're extremely racist i'm uh i
don't know about all everything having
to do with japan but i'm pretty sure
that
you can't function in japan like you
would struggle to get a job
you would struggle i don't think you can
even open a bank account as a white
person wow
yeah yeah it's because these are these
are ethno-national countries
they're they're very isolated and even
outside of this
go to sweden i interviewed someone in
sweden who said it was an american woman
she married a swedish man
she spoke fluent swedish with an accent
she couldn't get a job
because they knew she wasn't swedish
it's just about are you a part of the
majority
otherwise people have a bias against you
i think that exists
so look there's a lot of a lot of issues
that come up where i'm like
i'm center left especially on like some
social issues
but what i think the left is doing right
now the leftists is they're
not offering up real solutions to the
problems so they get it so they can
control you so they can take your
resources
so you will be their foot soldier or
their minion if they actually told you
the solution to many of these problems
may have something to do with
some social programs but ultimately your
responsibility right
you're letting people go you're saying
let me teach you how to start a fire
so i look at it this way if i said
i am going to start a program where we
teach people how to fish
that's a social program but you're
letting people go
yes what they do is they say we're gonna
start a program where
we have people fish and then we make the
people come in here and do what we want
and we
will maybe give them one right it's a
big big difference yes
so for me i think it's probably a really
good way to explain how i
you know i feel like i'm center left i
think if the government was like we're
gonna teach you how to fish and then
you're on your own
and you can do this on your own that's a
social program that makes sense
agree especially with restrictions so
that
you know the way i often put it is you
can't just create a program
and expect it to run forever it has to
have an end date an expiration and then
you reassess
and try other things if they're not
working and update and renew instead we
don't do that
we just keep doing the same thing over
and over again regardless the welfare
system never changes it just gets worse
and more money piled into it
but i i think there's room for that
that's more of a you know center-left
position
so anyway yeah so when it comes to
privilege
um people have privileges i do believe
that men have some privileges
women have some privileges too you want
to have an argument who has more i don't
think you'll ever solve that argument i
don't think anyone will ever be able to
actually win as to who has it better a
man or a woman
men will argue oh they've been
expendable for all throughout history
and they're you know young men have very
little societal value with no skills no
reproductive value
and young women have tremendous value to
society because they're attractive and
they can you know have kids and stuff
you can argue those things are offensive
and wrong that's fine the point is
you're gonna have an argument all day
night about who is more privileged and
you'll never win
i think ultimately you're gonna be delta
handicards and some people might get a
really crappy hand but i truly believe
you can figure it out i agree if you
believe in yourself
some people need help i did i had i i
had uh i lost my job at one point i went
on unemployment for for for quite a long
time
and it allowed me to survive and i was i
had no idea what to do at this point
it was during you know around the the
time of the financial crisis and i was
you know i was really young
and it was it was it was crap money it
was a couple hundred bucks a month
but it kept me off the street and then
eventually i figured something out i got
a job i started working at non-profits
and i was like that was awesome but if
you get people dependent on it
that's what i think the left is going
for right now right you can't solve your
problems because you can never change
the color of your skin therefore
join my group and enact my laws it's a
trojan horse so they can get things
like socialism and you know just well
and you know
unemployment is an insurance that we pay
into
right as well i mean you know and i
think that it
does absolutely save and help a lot of
people for
and it's temporary you know it's right
it goes as long as it goes but it's yeah
i mean when you're talking about
taking able-bodied healthy capable
people
and putting them on a cycle of welfare
and
food stamps and all of these different
things and then basically you know it
becomes
not an addiction but i mean it just
becomes a way of life i think for a lot
of people and then you start to
they they they're how why would you be
motivated to do anything else
you just sort of get settled into your
circumstances i think these programs can
work but they need a cultural component
we don't have anymore like you said it
becomes a way of life i know people like
this i lived in seattle and there were
people who were like here's the food
banks you hit on which day
so they're like they had a chart where
like monday is this neighborhood
tuesdays this neighborhood they they
created a system
to go and get free stuff and i'm like
i'm going to go get a job because i'm
bored
i want to do something and i want to
choose for myself when i eat not go to a
food bank and just be like give me that
last can of beans
but for them it was like but it's so
much easier to just get the last can of
beans
right i was like you look you do your
thing but because they never
you know the requirements for these food
banks was walk on in
people had no incentive to do anything
they were they they were they were given
and they built a life around it i have a
friend uh
well he's not really a friend anymore
again one of the 90 percent gone
but um he he's been on social programs
for
years and years and
it's so interesting because the way that
they keep him on it he's required
to like go to certain doctor's
appointments on a regular basis to
continue to validate his
condition which keeps him on so i mean
it's like it's a regular cycle that he
has to go see a certain number of
doctors every week
and he which of course they pay for but
it's there's not even time to do any and
i i've told him i
i haven't talked to him in years but i
was like wouldn't it be easier to just
get a job
you know i mean you have to leave and go
sit in these appointments and get these
doctors to do all this stuff so just go
work
dude like you know i think
a lot of people don't know how and i
think it's the fault of
of our culture i think schools do a
terrible job i was lucky enough to have
an entrepreneurial family
that instilled values in me for hard
work and you know building things on
your own
but a lot of people don't know where to
even start
so i i get messages from people all the
time saying i really would love to do my
own business i don't even know how to
start doing that
and i'm like i'll tell you what i did i
just went off and started doing stuff
yeah that's literally i i got a i got on
a bus went to new york during occupy
wall street i had a backpack i slept
outside
and then i just from there you know i i
worked at a non-profit
i saved up some money i bought a
smartphone i had a smartphone then i
you know so what i do tell people let's
see what you do figure out what you want
to do
find a job save money from that job and
then use that money you save
to start funding your ex your your your
learning cur like your your learning
period and your development period for
your passion
right and then try and figure it out and
not everybody can
and be willing to accept that you're
gonna fail probably many times along the
way
i uh i i failed many many many times
in my life many times before i ended up
in this position that i'm in now
and i i certainly had never created a
movement
against the democratic party before i
didn't have a lot of experience you know
but i
after failing at many different things
in my life and i had no idea that
walkway was going to become what i mean
it started as a facebook group
but um when it really resonated with
people and became really successful i i
thought you know there's something much
larger here than just a testimonial
campaign on facebook
i think that this is something that's
needed by the public at large and so we
created an
organization walkway foundation and um
started doing events and
some of the things we do hit some of
them don't hit we learn from that we
move on and that's kind of how life is
you just you know
i think it's funny uh when i first saw
your viral video for walk away
there were a lot of people when it got
really big they were saying that it was
existing trump supporters pretending
they left the democratic party it was
astroturf and stuff like that
russian bots russian bots and i was just
like but i actually know a lot of people
like a ton of people like uh jack murphy
he wrote a book democrats deportable
nine million people who have obama voted
for trump yeah
and is there stories of the inverse did
you i don't know if you heard about this
but the dnc featured a man who claimed
he was a lifelong republican
who is now you know who's now going to
vote democrat and they track down his
information turns out he's a registered
democrat
he he he's not he's not a republican do
you know his name
his name was michael or something and
they were like this guy donated
donated to and for like the last five
elections voted for a democrat or
whatever
well i don't know if you saw i think it
was on the first night of the convention
uh the democrat convention they did this
like walk away rip-off
yeah that's what i'm talking about right
and it was a compilation and everyone
was like
67 and white and they were like i'm
walking away
from the republican party and i was like
this is the word like do you honestly
think this is gonna damage what i'm
doing
this is like a joke i mean we actually
have like young hip
black people gay people white people
like you know
and then they just put up all everything
that they claim that we are
they're like like look at all the people
leaving the republican party that's not
true
you know look man we're having fun we we
we laughed a whole lot on this show
and you you you see that somewhat with
with the left but man it is hard to tell
a joke on the left
the the comedians get cancelled shows
are getting canceled family guy
announced they can't do gay jokes
anymore
i'm like oh dude yeah they did they're
like we're not gonna do anything
they're still doing jewish jokes it's
the most ridiculous thing it's like dude
they're jokes we
like if if you've got a weak society
that can't understand what a joke is
why is that our fault why is it everyone
else's fault it's a ridiculous it's a
ridiculous notion that we must
or that we possibly could prevent all
offense it's bad enough
that it exists in general but when it
happens even within the community itself
like
i found it so disturbing when rupaul
announced that she was no longer going
to use the term she mail
on her show because there was a segment
i don't know if you watched drag race no
i don't you do well you're missing out
yeah it's a good show but there was a
there was a segment at the beginning of
every episode where
uh you know that she was doing a play on
email and they would
they would say you've got she-male and
apparently
trans activists not actual transgender
people
right right you know like non-binary
gender fluid
angry leftists like came down and so
now a drag queen can't say she-male
anymore on a show about
trans people and drag queens you hear
about what happened in the uk where a
woman posted rap lyrics to her instagram
i'm pretty sure she was black and the
n-word was in the lyrics she got
arrested for it
wow that's i hope we don't end up like
the uk well
you know one of my lgbt town halls last
year well
four out of five were actually uh
cancelled by the venue we did find a new
venue we pressed on it happened but
we filed a lawsuit against the venue in
new york city for canceling us
uh just days before the event because
not only did they cancel us but they
canceled us because
of leftist um you know activists coming
in and harassing the venue but the
leftists actually created a dossier
on so my panel was me mikey harlow and
blair white
and they went through all of our social
media and found these you know
the evidence that were white
supremacists and anti-gay and all of
this stuff
which for anybody in your audience who
cares all of our lgbt
all walk away town halls are available
for people to watch for free on youtube
so you can see the content that actually
exists
that they were trying to prevent from us
get it's very tame it's very productive
it's very positive
very uplifting in many ways but anyway
we filed a lawsuit against the lgbt
center of new york city who were the
ones who canceled us
and uh just a couple of weeks ago the
judge
in new york city threw out the case and
when she threw out the case what she
cited was
that upon uh researching
me and blair and mikey whatever she
agreed
that we were and i'm this is a quote
unquote
engaging in anti-queer slurs
and therefore we were dangerous to our
community and basically that we had it
coming
now queer is a slur yeah i mean it is a
word
that people like my there's nobody on
set on the center or on the right
who wants to be called queer the only
people who are pushing for this word
are lgbt radical activists it's a
disgusting word
i don't want to be called queer but the
judge said a straight woman
said that a two gay men and a
transgender woman
were anti-queer and therefore
we our case was thrown out uh of court i
think you gotta uh you should file a
human rights complaint
when did this happen oh just weeks ago
that's a human rights violation
if uh she actually used that word she
did and she was straight
she did yeah that i don't know how that
works with the government but when it
comes to
i believe general public account public
accommodation in new york city it's a
250 000
fine for a willful violation well
perhaps i'll look into that angle of the
case but you know it's i i'm very
curious to know what this judge would
have to say
uh about black people using the n-word
and you know if
she would throw a case out if uh if a
black person used the n-word at a public
event
did you use the word or she was she was
the one who used the word no but if if
her point is that we are engaging in
anti-queer slurs to the queer community
which we are part of
um i would consider the n-word to be a
slur and i hear a lot of black people
using it so i wonder if their cases
would be thrown out of court if that
ever happened
no we weren't but i think you you might
actually have a
she used a slur it is i mean steven
crowder got demonetized
you're right because he said that word
and he didn't say it in the context
where he was trying to be hurtful
he just said it yeah we said it about
somebody who was gay
right somebody who who describes
themselves in many of those ways crowded
and he probably describes himself as
queer that person
so actually in reference to crowder the
things he was saying about
i'm not gonna say that guy's name the
guy from vox i don't want to give me
attention
i know his name but i can't think of it
i'd say no i just i just i
i for one i don't i don't want to start
a brigade but most people know his but
the point is
he did a segment where he called himself
all of these names and crowder was
responding saying well okay mister
you know and then we'll say a word and
they they accused they claimed that he
was targeting him
yeah so yeah anyway when it comes to new
york i think
i've looked at all of i've looked at
these laws before i've actually done a
couple segments on them and i've talked
to some lawyers
sounds like they violated your human
rights by using that using that word
against you
and then arguing that you were in
violation of it imagine if
if that uh if that judge said to you
know candace owens
you're engaging in you know anti-n-word
you know behavior sure yeah that would
be that would be a major
you know controversy and everything
right yeah yeah
yeah it definitely would be um and you
know the thing is too
to me the biggest you know tragedy of
the whole thing
is that so many as these
you know when they do this they don't
just you know cancel your event it
becomes a story
and then those stories are used to
cancel you in the future
right when you try to do another event
in another city and they google you and
then they're like oh you have a history
of going around the country with your
anti-queer uh yeah anti-queer show
you know and um and the truth is
that i really would love for ev
certainly every lgbt person but even
people who aren't
watch what we've done with walk away you
know we've done black town halls we've
done hispanic town halls we've done uh
lgbt town halls they're like i said you
can watch them on youtube
but this is about providing more freedom
more opportunity
more choice to people we don't like if
you do
if if you don't want to walk away from
the left don't
i can't make you do it but just be
willing to listen to the reasons why i
think that we're being manipulated we're
being
used we're being targeted uh we're being
lied to we're being brainwashed
in in many respects and if you agree
with me
then just consider like maybe making
some some
some different choices in your life but
i mean
like why are we preventing people from
hearing words right exactly no one has
to go i'm not going into anyone's house
i'm putting a gun to their head i'm
throwing an event that they're free to
come to of their own volition that's
that's the problem
you're teaching people you're breaking
them out they're telling you you can't
solve your own problems and you're
saying the inverse you're saying the
opposite
you can you can go out there and do your
own thing don't listen to them just
right find your own truth
that's bad for them right they don't
want to lose cold members and it kind of
goes back to the point i was making
earlier about you know can republicans
evolve why can't republicans evolve if
democrats are allowed to
evolve i mean the people on the left
would say that well we're the ones who
believe in you know freedom and
opportunity and all this stuff and
we're the ones protecting minority
communities well if you really believe
in freedom and opportunity then you have
to be willing to let these minority
communities go
because you don't own them you can't
clutch them you can't grab them and
imprison them
if you believe that they have choice and
freedom you have to be willing to let
them go
to the republican party or anywhere else
that they want to go you can't just hold
them
and that's what we're trying to do but
you know it's ultimately about the
individuals in those communities
i you know there's a lot of polls that
have come out showing trump having
record approval from the black community
and i think that's terrifying the
democrats because you had emerson
which is considered to be one of the
most one of the most credible polls
saying that trump's approval was 30
now many polls are saying it's like
eight or 12 but trump had like three or
four polls
showing him at around 30 or so percent
res musan
consistently shown over the past several
months that trump's approval rating from
likely voters in the black community is
like 30 to 40 percent
like it's just insane numbers but we
have to wait and see because you know
they were saying that in 2018 too and
the midterm elections did not show that
at all right so um i'm not
i don't hang my my my hat on any pulls
you know whatsoever but particularly i
mean because that's
that really affects i think um i i mean
it speaks to my effectiveness to
walk away in what we're doing i hope to
god we see
some significant movement from
minorities and i really believe that we
will
i mean the the only crazy thing would be
you know
if all of these minorities who have
created walkaway stories
don't vote or if they it's possible do
something stupid and change their mind
or something but
i mean if walkaway is a is a true
indicator
of what is going to happen uh in 2020
then i think that we're going to see a
significant
dent and it's going to be glorious i
think
trump's going to win you know but but
you know don't
don't get complacent thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you